un día histórico así calificó el
presidente de Ucrania bolodimir selenski
la retoma de la ciudad de gerson al sur
del país ocupada por el ejército ruso
desde el inicio de la guerra Hoy es un
día histórico estamos recuperando el sur
del país estamos recuperando jersón
los habitantes de gerson recibieron en
las tropas ucranianas una escena similar
se vivió en kiev donde cientos de
desplazados de gerson se congregaron en
el centro de la capital del país estamos
felices agradecemos a nuestras fuerzas
armadas de Ucrania la celebración tiene
fundamento para el kremlin la pérdida de
la sureña gerson es el tercer golpe y
uno de los más fuertes en la invasión a
Ucrania luego de las retiradas de kiev y
de harkif hasta hace unas horas gerson
era la única capital de provincia
hermanos rusas y que había sido
integrada unilateralmente mediante un
referendo su control es vital para
definir nuevas estrategias de la guerra
con un eventual asedio a crimea
península obsesionada por Rusia desde
2014 y cuyo abastecimiento se verá
afectado ya que una de las únicas dos
rutas de conexión con este territorio
era jerson pero la postura rusa no
cambia
moscúa asegura que el repliegue no
cambia el estatus quo el portavoz del
Ministerio de defensa de Rusia remarcó
la seguridad de las tropas y el
equipamiento militar durante La retirada
la transferencia de unidades de tropas
rusas a la orilla izquierda del río
nieper se completó a las 5 de la mañana
hora Moscú de este viernes ni una sola
pieza del equipo militar quedó en la
orilla derecha Todo el personal del
servicio ruso cruzó a la orilla
izquierda del río nieper
Mientras tanto la atención en los
alrededores de gerson continúa el
control de la Costa Sur del mar Negro es
un eslabón importante tanto para la
ofensiva rusa como para la
contraofensiva ucraniana